va a ser una noche con mucha sorpresa es
muy emocionante en la que también
escucharemos algunas figuras destacadas
dentro del partido que precisamente van
a apoyar esta hoja de ruta que
comentábamos que va a apostar por la que
va a apostar you buy the vamos a
escuchar precisamente a cuatro
candidatos que también se presentaron en
las primarias para conseguir la
candidatura demócrata y luchar contra
donald trump políticamente en estas
elecciones del 3 de noviembre
escucharemos al senador cor y brooke
escucharemos también al alcalde pitbull
y incluso al ex alcalde de la ciudad de
nueva york michael bloomberg va a ser
una noche como digo muy interesante en
la que también el presidente don al
trama ha anunciado que estará realizando
varios eventos de campaña en pueblecitos
de pensilvania precisamente en uno muy
cercano a donde nació el propio
candidato demócrata joe biden y además
podría entrar por teléfono en el
programa de la cadena fox para ofrecer
una entrevista justo en el momento en el
que joe biden estaría recibiendo
formalmente su nominación en un intento
como hemos visto en estas últimas
jornadas de recoger la atención de los
medios de comunicación en medio de la
celebración de esta convención demócrata